[Music]
so this morning something crazy happened
we received our first true look at
Avengers 4 through a photo that was
leaked this is the first promo art that
has been released for Avengers 4 there
are actually two photos that have been
released this morning but before we get
started and dive into these videos be
sure to subscribe to my channel to stay
up to date on Avengers 4 so we'll start
with this photo first and it shows all
of the Avengers that were not wiped out
by Thanos a snap but we also have some
additions if you take a look Hawkeye
finally made his appearance and he's
still sporting a boat and he appears to
have his same outfit on that he does
through most of the movies so it appears
that he has not taken on too persona of
Ronan yet also you can take a look to
his right you can see Ant Man
a man was absent during infinity war but
I think it's safe to say that in ant-man
on the watch that comes out next month
we'll find out exactly what was
happening with him and the wasp during
the whole infinity war timeframe but
there's something else to notice here
and that the wasp isn't here it seems
like maybe she didn't survive the snap
and I'm gonna say that she didn't
because I think that if she did she
would be in this photo right here again
I think it's going to be revealed to us
what happens with ant-man and the wasps
during the times of infinity war in
ant-man in the wasp movie and I think
it'll probably be in a post-credits
scene kind of the same as in the
post-credits scene of infinity war that
showed Nick Fury and agent Hill kind of
disappearing I think it will kind of be
the same thing I think it'll be there
sitting fine and dandy they've defeated
ghosts and then all of a sudden people
start to disappear and the next thing
you know hope disappears and then maybe
even Hank Pym disappears ant-man is like
what the heck is going on and that's
when he goes and finds the Avengers the
next addition to the original Avengers
is Rocket Raccoon
I think rocket is going to make a great
addition to the Avengers I mean rocket
Groot and Thor's quest
Tonetta Villere was amazing it was
definitely one of the best scenes
in the whole entire movie and he
definitely bonded with Thor during the
movie and Thor is still alive thank
goodness so I think it's gonna be really
great to see this dynamic again plus I
think he's gonna add some much-needed
humor because let's face it the end of
infinity war it's pretty dark and I
think the start of Avengers 4 will be
pretty dark as well and I think rocket
is gonna provide some very necessary
humor and while we're talking about
guardians there is another one in this
photo
sort of there's nebula nebula isn't so
much of a hero as she is an antihero but
nonetheless I think she's going to be of
extreme importance in Avengers 4 she is
the adopted daughter of Thanos he raised
her so she knows him extremely well and
not to mention that in the Infinity
Gauntlet series she is the one that
Ashley wields the Infinity Gauntlet and
helps defeat Thanos so I think we'll see
some big things from nebula and last but
certainly not least is the one and only
Captain Marvel she is wearing her
original outfit that she does in the
comics when she becomes Captain Marvel
and we've seen some leaked photos of her
in this outfit but we've also seen some
leaked photos of her in the green outfit
as well so it's good to see that she's
actually in the red and blue outfit
she's supposed to be the heavy hitter in
Avengers 4 right she is who Nick Fury
was calling at the end of infinity war
in the post-credits scene when everybody
was disappearing another thing about
Captain Marvel is I've said this before
and it has been rumored that she's going
to be wearing quantum bands and these
are the quantum bands that Kwas are
wears in the comics now this is
obviously a shift of how it is in the
comics but the thing about the quantum
bands is when the user wears them they
can turn invisible so it's hard to know
if this rumor is true she could be
wearing them in this photo and they just
might be invisible so we don't really
know but regardless it's just really
awesome to see her finally with all of
the other Avengers the original Avengers
look the same for the most part with the
exception of a few things but you can
see here
Ironman still has his nanotechnology
suit
Captain America still looks the same as
he did in infinity war Thor still looks
the same any still rocking Stormbreaker
as you can see here in the photo Black
Widow
seems to be wearing the same outfit that
she normally does in the movies and
she's still rocking the katanas
Warmachine looks a tad bit different but
for the most part the same maybe Tony
gave them some nanotechnology and that's
what his suit is now but for the most
part it looks the same the gun on top
looks a little different it doesn't look
like a Gatling gun like it normally is
so maybe it is nanotech and he's just
kind of coming up with a different gun
on top or maybe it's some sort of a
Content technology now the biggest
difference in change in appearance in
this photo is obviously the Hulk he's
wearing some sort of suit or uniform
which we never see now when banner turns
into the Hulk obviously all of his
clothes rip off except for his pants for
obvious reasons but all of his clothes
besides that do rip off now he's already
the Hulk in this photo so that means
he's already went from tiny banner to
huge Hulk and the suit is still on now
that leads me to believe that this is a
very specifically designed suit probably
by him and Tony and it's definitely
designed to expand with him now
what this really looks like is Professor
Hulk now professor Hulk is kind of a
merger and in the comics there's
actually kind of - there's the merged
Hulk and slash the professor Hulk but
they're kind of the same characters so
in this photo we're talking about
professor Hulk he is a merger between
Banner and the Hulk kind of becoming one
person
Mark Ruffalo has even said it interviews
that they'll dine between Banner and the
Hulk is beginning to get blurred so
Banner and the Hulk are kind of starting
to merge into one person and of course
to mention that Bruce Banner in the
films is beginning to worry that when he
turns into the Hulk he might never come
back in thor ragnarok we learned that
when the Hulk left in Avengers age of
Ultron he remained in the Hulk State for
two years so he's really worried that if
he turns back in the Hulk it's just
gonna be the whole the Hulk's gonna take
over and it's never gonna come back to
Bruce Banner
so this problem and banner worrying
about this kind of
smoothly brings in professor Hulk
because in the comics Bruce Banner
subconsciously installs a type of
safeguard within professor Hulk and
basically what happens with this
safeguard is when the Hulk gets too
angry he'll turn back into Bruce Banner
so you can clearly see how this is a
great way to kind of transition into
professor Hulk because right now
currently Banner is really worried that
when he turns back into the Hulk the
Hulk will take control and he'll never
turn back into banner again so I think
this is super exciting because I would
love to see different variations of the
Hulk and I think professor Hulk will be
really cool to see on screen another
thing about this photo is that it
appears to be on Titan now obviously
it's not the same color it's not red but
if you look at the background it really
does look like Titan I think the whole
blue background in this photo is simply
just because it's just because of the
promo art they chose to make it blue but
I think it's tight and it really looks
like it and I'm not actually sure if
that has any significance at all I mean
obviously it has significance to danos
and to infinity war because of the scene
that took place on Titan but I don't
think that this is implying too much
here I don't think Titan will play too
big of a significance in Avengers 4 I
think if anything they might revisit
thanasis childhood somehow the Russo
brothers said about infinity war that
they cut out a lot of scenes about
Thanos has passed
maybe these cut out scenes will make
their way in Avengers 4 and we'll learn
more about the noses backstory but I
think that probably is the extent of the
significance of Titan I don't think
they'll really revisit it that much so
that's that for the first photo let's
take a look at the second photo which is
of Thanos this photo of Thanos is pretty
cool because he's wearing his battle
armor I know a lot of fans were pretty
disappointed with infinity war because
he never really wore his battle armor he
had it in the very beginning but he took
it off pretty quickly and never put it
on again but he has it on in this photo
so maybe that means we'll see more of it
in Avengers 4 and as you can see he's
wildung a noose
now I know that there were toys of fan
OHS released earlier in the year before
infinity war came out where he actually
had this sword I'm not sure if this is
of any significance but what it might
say is that we will see those cut scenes
from the first Avengers in Avengers 4
because if you think about it they came
out with a toys which means that were
probably scenes for infinity war with
feyo's wielding the sword they made the
toys after the scenes then they took the
scenes out but they made the toys and
you're not gonna not sell toys so maybe
we'll see those scenes come back in
Avengers 4 another thing to notice is
that his Infinity Gauntlet is fixed at
the end of Infinity Ward you can notice
that the Infinity Gauntlet was pretty
banged up and that is from him using the
power of all the Infinity stones to wipe
out half the universe but it probably
wouldn't be too hard for him to just use
the time stone to fix the Infinity
Gauntlet
so what this photo really tells me for
the most part is that Thanos is ready
for battle he's got his armor on he's
got his new sword and the Infinity
Gauntlet is fixed I hope Captain Marvel
packs a serious punch because the
Avengers are gonna need everything that
they have in order to defeat Thanos
in Avengers 4 so that is it for these
first leaks promo art photos for
Avengers 4 hopefully this is just the
start of more news and info about it
coming out let me know what your
thoughts are about it in the comments
below and be sure to LIKE this video if
you enjoyed it and also be sure to
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on Avengers 4 thank you so much for
watching Wolfgang wolf wolf
[Music]
[Music]